In this course, we're using WebGL and developers library I chose for this course called the
Three.js. WebGL is an Application Program Interface, API for short, that
controls the GPU. It is based on OpenGL ES, an API used in mobile devices which
in turn is based on OpenGL, an API for desktop computers that dates back to
1992. The other major competing API is called DirectX or Direct3D, which is
commonly used for games on the Xbox console and Windows PCs. This is almost the
last time I'll mention DirectX. It's not all that different from WebGL. In fact,
Google Chrome on the PC turns WebGL commands into DirectX calls. See additional
course materials for more information. WebGL itself is a state based API. You
set up exactly how you want the GPU to do something, then send a geometry to
render under these conditions. This gives a pretty fine grained control over the
GPU that can result in hundreds of lines of code that draw even the simplest
scenes. This is why we'll be using Three.js, a free development library with
many useful features. Just a few lines of code in Three.js can create objects
with materials, set up lighting and a camera, and even perform animation.